brothers and sisters yes
no it's not alcohol it's not champagne
it's
apple juice yes it's apple juice guys um
why am i doing this video i have fizzy
apple juice i have water i have normal
apple juice i have cranberry juice
why am i doing this video these are the
drinks that are in my fridge that is how
blessed i am that i can go to my fridge
and think
should i have cranberry with my food nah
i'll have a bit of water
i'll have apple juice if not i'll have
the fizzy version of it
that is how blessed we are
in these lands well can you call it
blessing maybe these are the reasons
that's going to be our destruction what
we think is blessing could be a
destruction don't think that when allah
gives you everything it means that he's
happy with you it could also mean he's
happy with you don't get it twisted my
point in this video is very simple
bronze sisters there are people around
the world who don't even have drinking
water clean drinking water
how could i live in my house knowing i
have all these luxuries
any food that i like so many biscuits
and chocolates
and that people are in those countries
they don't even have clean water the
prophet salallahu sallam said the best
form of sadaqah is what to give water
water water
people the scientists travel to
different parts to find life on
different planets and the first thing
they look for is water
guys
please help me link in the link below to
reach my target inshallah by donating
while i we have to do our part we cannot
live a life put our head on our pillow
comfortably and with our families
knowing people i don't care if they're
muslim or not
that are starving or they are thirsty
they don't have water to drink and they
have to travel kilometers and some of
these women get raped and take advantage
of just to get water some of these kids
can't go to school because they need to
go and fetch a water
please i'm urging you for the sake of
allah i am working with muslim aid
australia to get this target to be
reached to have water wells that will
last for 10 15 years 15 years of goodies
can you imagine every droplet of animals
insects agriculture humans
drink water
do we do have their worship you will get
the reward that's all i'm going to say
donate in the link below assalamu
alaikum warahmatullahi wabarakatuh